did addison ray just get the boot from
tick tock life has changed so much
not so fast it all went down on thursday
when the 21 year old social media star
shared this screenshot on twitter of a
notice she says she received that her
tick tock account yeah it was apparently
given the axe quote your account was
permanently banned due to multiple
violations of our community guidelines
i'm kind of just living life day by day
and not too worried about anything of
course addison skyrocketed to fame on
the app she currently has over 85
million followers and she poked fun at
the whole band thing tweeting quote well
time to get a job right now i'm kind of
just going with the flow and who knows
what'll happen as of now it's unclear
what exactly prompted that message but
everything seems to be resolved and her
account is back online i just really
want to focus on my family my brands my
career and just really trying to shape
my life for the next five to ten years
and while tick tock may have launched
her career she's been pretty busy with
work outside of the social media
platform last month she signed a
multi-picture deal with netflix
partnering with the streaming service to
develop new movies for her to act in and
executive produce
that's kind of like always been my
dreams like be on the big screen
back in 2020 addison told et she wanted
to parlay her tick tock fame to the big
screen in the next year i really am
pushing to get into acting really hard
right now so i've been on a lot of
auditions and like castings and stuff
like that so hopefully in the next year
i'll be casted in a movie or tv show
well flash forward to 2021 and addison
spoke it into existence she made her
acting debut in netflix's he's all that
a new twist on the 90s classic i will
create the next prom king you make it
sound so easy you don't think i can do
it
e.t chatted with a triple threat about
the milestone moment leading up to the
august premiere it's
yeah indescribable it's a dream come
true to say the least and um the
experience every single part of it was
just so magical and something i'll never
forget it really is hard to put it into
words and i think um i feel like most
people can relate to that you know in
your first debut it's like you don't
really know how to feel you don't know
what to say it's just so exciting and
i'm just really hoping everyone enjoys
it as much as i enjoy doing it addison
also attended the met gala in september
and dropped a single titled obsessed
back in march
[Music]
so needless to say tick tock or no tick
tock addison has plenty going on
[Music]